what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible yes we are we
are back with invincible i left you guys
on an insane cliffhanger in the last
video
so much that you guys were cursing me up
and down because i left you guys in a
cliffhanger so in the last video what we
basically had was rex right robot if you
guys want to call him that it's it's
interchangeable it's all basically the
same thing this guy had launched his
campaign to do what was essentially him
taking over the world or at least that's
how it appeared and that when monster
girl had figured out what it was that he
was doing he had basically like
literally had her taken away and then
shot out into space where she
essentially suffocated now as you guys
can probably guess although maybe you
didn't guess because the reality here is
that robert kirkman in a lot of ways
treats invincible like game of thrones
right anybody can die at any time
monster girl is of course saved right
she's basically rescued by one of the
viltrumites and then taken to uh taken
to the the viltromite base in order to
essentially be covered now while that's
going on remember adam eve even though
she was pregnant was attacked by one of
the robots from rex who released one of
his drones and her leg was blown off and
so in the midst of all that when she's
taken to a base through to recover and
recuperate she of course they also end
up having to deliver the baby now the
big concern here for mark right off the
bat is that while adam eve is alive
she's currently in surgery and there's
no guarantee that she can survive right
the trauma of having a baby is already
pretty high when you compound that with
the amount of blood loss she sustained
from losing a leg basically you could be
looking at a situation where between
shock and bleeding to death she
essentially dies now of course she does
recover which is exactly what we would
expect here right she does end up
recovering and basically of course
mark's you know mark brings the baby to
her and she holds it for the very first
time of course a very sentimental moment
but it's one of those things where in
the end uh when adam eve goes to touch
mark he shies away now this is not a
result of the struggles between adam eve
and her relationship with mark remember
mark is now a victim of sexual assault
and so in those instances you ever read
any interviews about anybody who's ever
gone through that and they react in all
kinds of different ways for example one
of the things that victims will do is
they'll wear their shoes to bed because
they'll believe that if you know had
they had their shoes on the first time
that they would have been able to run
away or something along those lines it's
not to say they're wrong it's simply
their coping mechanism with how they
deal with the trauma of that situation
now of course again it's one of these
things where his victimizer really kind
of comes around and she had said that
the first time right that like you know
they'll probably like she'll probably
end up forcing herself on mark multiple
times in order you know in order to get
herself to the point that she can
conceive it's one of those things where
kirkman is kind of like yeah it happened
it's there but he also kind of glosses
over it to a degree which is
particularly interesting but what you
also end up getting is one of the drones
of rex which shows up and is met by the
arrival of all the viltrumites now
remember right now nolan is the leader
of the viltrumite race freddie mercury's
been ousted he hasn't been killed but
freddie mercury's been ousted right he's
basically been exiled from the vulture
might race and told to just go somewhere
else but in the moment where you end up
having rex of course having this
conversation with nolan he's also you
know attacking all your superheroes and
so on and so forth and there's even a
point where he meets with the president
of the united states where the
implication here is that he intends to
kill the president right but the
important thing is that as he's talking
uh with with nolan he basically says
like we should work together right it's
one of those things where it's kind of
interesting because he says i believe
you have found yourself working at cross
purposes your main objective is to live
here in peace and to produce offspring
with humans in secret to pull your
people from the brink of extinction and
to compound that right rex goes as far
as to say and yet you want to stop me
here right i'm sure your your scientists
have already pointed out how diminished
your gene pool is with your dwindling
ranks do you really want to risk losing
more in a fight with me and that's
what's interesting because he says were
you two oppose me i have no doubt you
would succeed you would take over this
entire planet easily but again not
without losing some of your own so a
fight is unwise for both of us and i
have no desire to fight you my ultimate
goal is to create a utopian society on
earth to do away with all the danger in
turmoil that takes place there regularly
so to create a perfect breeding ground i
propose we work together and that's the
interesting thing here right because one
of the things to keep in mind and we'll
talk about this more as we get further
into the story that robot's motivation
here is not so basic as to just like
plant himself as a dictator of the world
what he's shooting for is something a
lot more interesting and more
philosophical and something that we've
routinely talked about and so we don't
necessarily see the nature of the
conversation beyond that between robot
and the vulture mites instead once mark
arrives on the scene the sim the the
whole thing is okay like i believe we're
done here and the response of of nolan
is i'm afraid so and then when mark
arrives to basically you know attack the
this this robot and then also coming to
the conclusion that in the end like rex
is out there on a space station orbiting
earth they have to destroy him if they
want to destroy these robots that the
response of nolan is no right we need to
have a conversation we need to talk and
so essentially what nolan seems to do is
basically bring mark up to speed on
their on the nature of their
conversation and while we're not given
the the details the follow-up
conversation tells us everything we need
to know right like literally mark says
this doesn't make any sense to me this
can't be happening how could you do this
and the response of nolan is as emperor
i have a responsibility to my people to
our people i have to do what's best for
them and so in effect what he basically
says here is he struck a deal with robot
that what robot is looking to do here
because he wants to create a utopia
essentially that nolan's going along
with it now this is the complicated
nature of nolan's position as
essentially being the leader of the
viltrum right race that because he is
the leader of the viltrumides and
because the his people come first in the
end he has to do what's best for them
before he does what's best for earth
right i mean humanity is not currently
in a position to where it's facing
extinction at least not in the not in
the invincible world here in the real
world absolutely we are but in the the
vulture might world no right they're not
really dealing with that that's not a
major threat they have to focus on the
vulture might race there are a paltry
number of them and that with various
wars and skirmishes and conflicts the
writing is kind of on the wall at some
point in time in the near future there
could very well be some sort of nuclear
conflict or some conflict that could
turn earth into a place where it's
basically uninhabitable and the attempts
of the viltrumites to essentially
procreate and to bolster their numbers
would all come to ruin and so that's
kind of the funny thing is because
mark's like okay fine if you're not
gonna do anything about this then i will
right and then mark basically races off
to confront robot and nolan basically
lets him go right he essentially just
lets him do his thing now when he
arrives on the scene that's kind of the
funny thing here right when he arrives
here and starts to go against robot of
course rex basically uses their his
sonic pulse to kind of neutralize mark
again that's marks like big weakness
right like sonic energy and it's uh it's
cool that kirkman went with that because
up until the point where that was
introduced there was never anything to
indicate that mark really had an actual
weakness right that mark had some kind
of an achilles heel he was just a hybrid
between a human and a viltromite who
would just consistently get stronger
after every battle he fought until such
a point that he would basically be this
unstoppable force right so it's cool to
know that the viltrumites themselves
actually have a weakness that can be
exploited and so it's one of those
things where literally like what a where
mark kind of tries to fight a little bit
the response of rex is look man you
haven't even defeated one of me yet
alone like all these versions of me
right like i have built these robots in
order to confront you right you're the
most powerful of us so these robots have
to be able to overcome you and if they
can overcome you or at least stand
against you they can stand against
anybody else right so like you're the
bar you're the standard you can't defeat
one how could you possibly hope to
defeat dozens and so it's just like at
that point all these robots just
literally start coming out of nowhere
and it's like let's have a conversation
right let's talk about this and so this
is a really really cool thing here right
because in this conversation that they
have rex says like i have to begin by
pointing out the hypocrisy of you
opposing me how different is what i'm
doing any different than what you and
dinosaurus attempted to do and the mark
of course responds exactly how you would
expect right we only did things to make
people's lives better we didn't try to
take over the world and the response of
rex is and that's why you failed right
you left too many variables in play your
methods never had any chance of
succeeding but why won't you work with
me the same way you did with him i've
killed far fewer people than dinosaurs
or your father and yet you view me
differently is it really just because of
what i did to you personally i stranded
you in another dimension i ripped off
your girlfriend's leg would an apology
work
[Laughter]
that kind of a thing right trying to
understand and it's kind of funny
because rex says like i could have
killed you i could have killed eve but i
didn't i'm not a different person
suddenly right i'm not some kind of a
monster i didn't kill anybody that i
didn't have to i don't want to kill you
and he says like i like you right like
i'd send you back to that dimension if
the machine i constructed didn't require
lingering energy from angstrom levy to
work did you figure that out yet seems
those doorways died with him so
basically the ability to travel from one
dimension to the next by way of the
technology that angstrom levy left
behind is all basically gone this is
robert kirkman tying up loose ends right
this is robert kirkman wrapping things
up i mean that's one of the things i
hope you guys have noticed with this
comic so far is it's basically robert
kirkman killing off what's left of the
superhero community right like all these
different people who are there reducing
the number of superheroes who were out
there right in turn reducing or
eliminating the ability to travel to
different dimensions in effect he's
closing the walls in and so when mark
says like stop this madness the response
of rex is like like what madness are you
talking about i've assumed control of
over 100 law enforcement agencies
worldwide and the six hours since that
happened i've prevented over 9 000
deaths i've already put systems in place
that are changing the way crime is
fought he says i've already incarcerated
titans slaying mantis mauler and embrace
criminals who'd been at large for months
stopping this madness would cost lives
not save them so i'm asking why aren't
you willing to stay with me now this is
when mark basically comes out with a
kind of big guns and says i'm i'm
basically fighting a crazy person trying
to take over the world and that's where
rex like is that really what you think
this is me trying to take over the world
like i have no desire to take over the
world mark and he says i've assumed
control and that control will expand as
needed true but no one here knows what
i've done the public at large they'll
only ever see an improvement in their
lives they'll see a substantive change
in their quality of life and the way the
world works nothing more i will not put
a face on those differences there will
be no one person to receive blame or
credit and he says in a way i've
improved on what i did with the flaccid
dimension i'm fixing things from behind
the curtain if you somehow fought and
killed me you'd be executed for what
you've done i'm the good guy here mark
right if that's the simplified way you
want to look at things and he says you
know what this is you know the reason
why you're so against it mark is because
this is new it's a new way of doing
things of fighting evil of saving the
world and it's messy and it's imperfect
but it's effective but most of all it's
new do not be afraid of what's new
embrace it welcome it accept it but more
than anything else do not make me kill
you and that's that's the thing here
right this this is the interesting thing
here is that in the end what what what
we're talking about here with what rex
is wanting to do this guy he's not
looking to be some kind of a dictator
right he's not looking to be some kind
of a person who's going to rule over the
world from on high and have women
brought to him as he needs them and to
have all the resources he needs for
everything that he wants to do he's not
approaching this from like a selfish
place the conclusion that rex came to in
looking at humanity is that the freedom
that humanity has experienced over the
course of its existence has basically
been used by humanity to effectively
destroy itself right to create class
societies to differentiate between who
deserves what based on like political
religious or moral ideologies to
segregate people based on world views
but at the end of the day of what
relevance is that right like if you've
got a person starving and you got a
person that has more than they need then
why can't that person who has more than
they need give to the person who's
starving the thing that stops them from
doing that is their world view right
well i work to get to where i am so they
should have to work to get to where they
are for this is literally for no other
reason than that and looking at humanity
as a whole the philosophical perspective
here at least as far as robot is
concerned is humanity will not improve
itself unless humanity is made to
improve itself now a lot of people would
approach that perspective and say well
you can't make humanity change it
doesn't work that way but doesn't it
though like usually if you're whenever
you're talking about humanity
experiencing market improvements it
comes after conflict right take for
example like the post-world war ii
landscape the development of atomic
energy and then the development of like
microwaves and things like that right
the ability to use technology as it
existed to basically expand humanity out
in ways that were never thought possible
this is no different the difference here
is that it's one person making the
decision as opposed to groups of people
making the decision but if everything
that's happened with humanity over the
course of its existence and the violence
and all that kind of stuff that comes
with it is the result of groups of
people making decisions then can you
really make a credible argument that it
should stay that way especially when
you're talking about a person with a
higher level of intelligence a person
who is by and large regardless of how he
may look nothing more than just an
algorithm and then in turn going forward
from there right that in a lot of ways i
don't know how many guys have read world
war z but the statement of paul rediker
is the most absolute and and really the
best way to depict this here imagine
what the human race could achieve if it
would but set aside its own humanity and
so it's one of those really really cool
elements right it's one of the things i
love about this but the funny thing is
that even in the face of all of this of
of what he's doing the difficulty in
rex's decision comes by way of the fact
that he's got all these memories and all
these experiences with these people that
he's fought alongside when he fought
alongside his teammates when they were
younger when they eventually became part
of the guardians of the globe or at
least replaced the guardians of the club
right when the original rex flow died
and rex said in order to honor his
memory i will take his name and fight
crime in his name that way at least some
piece of him can continue on this idea
that when he was talking to monster girl
and simply saying like i don't want to
become the person who killed the zaxles
the way that i did right i don't want to
become this dark and violent and
horrible person he's kind of conflicted
in that way but the reality is seemingly
he's making the right call that he's
killed superheroes that he once called
friends but the truth about it is that
superheroes exist to maintain the status
quo superheroes exist to look around at
the world as it exists and to keep it
that way whereas rex's job and at least
the the job he's undertaken on his own
is to look around at the world as it is
and to say the world can be better and
if humanity doesn't want to make it
better then i will make humanity make it
better and that those superheroes who
exist out there because the nature of
them is to maintain the status quo they
would ultimately get in the way and in
the face of that they had to be removed
from the equation otherwise progress
could never happen so it's an
interesting concept right it's really
really cool i mean this is where the
story ends right you know where he's
basically mulling over all his
experiences and all that kind of stuff
but it's a it's a ridiculously great
philosophical story this is also one of
the reasons why i wanted to postpone
this for a separate video because i felt
like it deserved its own analysis absent
everything else that was going on right
basically it would have just taken too
long if we'd added into the other video
it would have been like a 40 47 minute
video and i know a lot of you guys would
be like rob i would love to see a 47
minute video that's cool but that also
causes problems for my channel right
with the youtube algorithm so you know i
gotta do what's best to grow my channel
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you guys think about this down in
the comment section and then we will go
forward next week with volume 21 which
is really really interesting so uh thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace